vengo de un país de belleza
ensangrentada
mi país No sólo es bello allí También
hay violencia
no Cómo puede conjugarse la violencia
con la muerte Cómo puede erupcionar la
biodiversidad de la vida con las danzas
de la muerte y el horror Quién es el
culpable de romper el encanto con el
terror
A quién o qué es el responsable de
ahogar la vida en las decisiones
rutinarias de la riqueza y del interés
quien nos lleva a la destrucción como
nación y como pueblo mi país es bello
porque tiene la selva amazónica la del
chocó las aguas las cordilleras de los
Andes y los océanos allí en esa selvas
semana oxígeno Planetario y se absorbe
el CO2 atmosférico una de esas plantas
que absorbe el CO2 entre millones de
especies es una de las más perseguidas
de la Tierra
como de lugar se busca su destrucción es
una planta amazónica en la planta de la
coca
planta Sagrada de los incas
como en un cruce de caminos paradójico
la selva que se intenta salvar es al
mismo tiempo destruida para destruir la
planta de Coca arrojan venenos y
glifosato en masa que corre por las
aguas detienen a los sus cultivadores y
los encarcelan por destruir o poseer la
hoja de la coca muere en un millón de
latinoamericanos asesinados y encarcelan
a dos millones de afros en América del
Norte
destruir la planta que mata gritan desde
el norte
destruirla pero la planta no es sino una
planta
más de las millones de especies que
parecen cuando desatan el fuego sobre la
selva
destruir la selva el Amazonas se
convirtió en la Consigna que sigue en
Estados y negociantes no importa el
grito de los científicos
bautizando la selva como uno de los
grandes Pilares climáticos para las
relaciones del Poder del mundo
la selva y sus habitantes son los
culpables de La plaga que las azota a
las relaciones de poder
las azota la adicción al dinero
a perpetuarse al petróleo a la cocaína y
a las drogas más duras para poder
anestesiarse más
nada más hipócrita que el discurso para
salvar la selva
la selva se quema señores mientras
ustedes hacen la guerra y juegan con
ella
la selva el pilar climático del mundo
desaparece con toda su vida
la gran Esponja que absorbe el CO2
Planetario Se evapora
la selva salvadora es vista en mi país
como el enemigo derrotar como la maleza
extinguir el espacio de la coca y de los
campesinos que la cultivan porque no
tienen más que cultivar es demonizado
para ustedes mi país No les interesa
sino para arrojarle venenos a sus selvas
llevarse a sus hombres a la cárcel y
arrojar a sus mujeres a la exclusión no
les interesa la educación del niño sino
matarle su selva y extraer el carbón y
el petróleo de sus entrañas la Esponja
que absorbe los venenos no sirve
prefieren arrojarle más venenos a la
atmósfera
nosotros les servimos para excusar los
vacíos y la soledades de su propia
sociedad que la llevan a vivir en medio
de las Burbujas de las drogas
les ocultamos sus problemas que se
niegan a reformar mejores declararle la
guerra a la selva a sus plantas a su
gentes mientras dejan quemar la selvas
mientras hipócritas persiguen las
plantas con venenos para ocultar los
desastres de su propia sociedad nos
piden más y más carbón más y más
petróleo para calmar la otra adicción la
del consumo la del poder la del dinero
Qué es más venenoso para el ser humano
la cocaína o el carbón o el petróleo
el dictamen del poder ha ordenado que la
cocaína es el veneno y debe ser
perseguida así Ella solo cause mínimas
muertes por sobredosis y más por las
mezclas que provoca su gran destinidad
dictaminada Pero en cambio el carbón y
el petróleo
deben ser protegidos
así su uso pueda extinguir a toda a toda
la humanidad
Estas son las cosas del poder mundial
cosas de la injusticia cosas de la
irracionalidad porque el poder mundial
se ha vuelto irracional
ven en la exuberancia de la selva en su
vitalidad lo lujurioso lo pecaminoso el
origen culpable de la tristeza de sus
sociedades
imbuidas en la profunda compulsión
ilimitada de tener de tener y de
consumir
cómo ocultar la soledad del corazón
en su sequedad en medio de sociedades
sin afectos
competitivas hasta encarcelar el alma en
la soledad si no es echando la culpa la
planta al hombre que la cultiva a los
secretos libertarios de la selva
según El poder irracional del mundo la
culpa no es del mercado que recorta la
existencia
la culpa es de la selva y de quienes la
habitan
las cuentas bancarias se han vuelto
ilimitadas los dineros guardados de los
más poderosos de la tierra ya no podrán
siquiera gastarse en el tiempo de los
siglos la tristeza de la existencia que
produce esa artificial convocatoria la
competencia la llenan con ruido y con
drogas la adicción al dinero y al tener
tiene otra cara la adicción a las drogas
en las personas que pierden la
competencia de la carrera
artificial en la que han transformado a
la humanidad
la enfermedad de la soledad no se cura
con el grifosato sobre las selvas no es
la selva la culpable la culpable su
sociedad educada en el consumo sin fin
en la confusión estúpida entre consumo y
felicidad que transmite eso sí que los
bolsillos del poder se llenen de dinero
la culpable de la adicción a las drogas
no es la selva es la irracionalidad de
su poder mundial
denle un golpe
de luz de razón a su poder
prendan de nuevo las luces del siglo
40 años ha durado la guerra contra las
drogas
si no corregimos el rumbo y esta se
prolonga otros 40 años
Estados Unidos ver a morir de sobredosis
a dos millones ochocientos mil jóvenes
por fentanilo que no se produce en
nuestra América Latina
verá millones de afros norteamericanos
será presados en sus cárceles privadas
el afro preso se convertirá en negocio
de empresas carceleras
morirán asesinados un millón de
latinoamericanos más
nos llenarán llenarán de sangre nuestras
aguas y nuestros Campos verdes verán
morir el sueño de la Democracia tanto en
América como en la American anglosajona
la democracia morirá allí donde nació en
la gran Atenas occidental Europea
por ocultar la verdad
verán morir la selva y las democracias
la guerra contra las drogas ha fracasado
la lucha contra la crisis climática ha
fracasado han aumentado los consumos
mortales de drogas suaves han pasado a
las más duras Se ha producido un
genocidio en mi continente y en mi país
han condenado a las cárceles a millones
de personas para Ocultar sus propias
culpas sociales le han echado la culpa a
la selva y sus plantas
han llenado de sin razón los discursos y
las políticas
yo les demando desde aquí desde mi
latinoamérica herida
acabar con la irracional guerra contra
las drogas
disminuir el consumo de drogas no
necesita de guerras de armas
necesita que todos construyamos una
mejor sociedad una sociedad más
solidaria más afectuosa donde la
intensidad de la vida salve de las
adicciones y de las nuevas esclavitudes
quieren menos drogas
piensen en menos ganancias y en más
amores
piensen en un ejercicio racional del
poder no toquen con sus venenos la
belleza de mi patria
ayúdennos sin hipocresías a salvar la
selva amazónica para salvar la vida de
la humanidad en el planeta
ustedes reunieron los científicos y
ellos hablaron con la razón
con matemáticas y modelos
climatológicos dijeron que se acercaba
el fin de la especie humana que su
tiempo ya no es de milenios ni siquiera
de siglos
la ciencia aprendió la alarma y dejamos
de escucharla la guerra nos sirvió de
excusa para no tomar las medidas
necesarias
cuando más se necesitaban las acciones
cuando los discursos ya no servían
cuando era indispensable depositar los
dineros en los fondos para salvar la
humanidad cuando había que alejarse
cuanto antes del Carbón y del petróleo
se inventaron una guerra y otra y otra
invadieron Ucrania pero también
Irak y Libia y Siria invadieron el
nombre del petróleo y del gas
descubrieron en El Siglo 21 la peor de
sus adicciones la adicción al dinero y
al petróleo
Las Guerras les han servido de excusa
para no actuar contra la crisis
climática Las Guerras les han mostrado
cuán dependientes son de lo que acabará
con la especie humana si observan que
los pueblos se llenan de hambre y de sed
y emigran por millones hacia el norte
hacia donde está el agua entonces
ustedes los encierran
construyen muros despliegan
ametralladoras les disparan
los expulsan como si no fueran seres
humanos
quien implican la mentalidad de quien
creó políticamente las cámaras de gas y
los campos de concentración
reproducen a escala planetaria 1933
el día del Gran triunfo del asalto a la
razón
Acaso no ven que la solución al Gran
Éxodo de su atado sobre sus países del
Norte es volver a que el agua llene los
ríos y los campos se llenen de
nutrientes el desastre climático nos
llena de virus que pululan
arrazándolas pero ustedes hacen negocios
con las medicinas y convierten las
vacunas en mercancías
Proponen que el mercado nos salvará de
lo que el mismo mercado ha creado el
Frankenstein de la humanidad
está en dejar actuar el mercado y la
codicia sin planificar rindiendo el
cerebro y la razón
arrodillando la racionalidad humana a la
codicia
para que la guerra si lo que necesitamos
es salvar la especie humana
para qué sirve la otan y los imperios si
lo que viene es el fin de la
inteligencia el desastre climático
matará centenares de millones de
personas y Oigan bien no lo produce el
planeta lo produce el capital la causa
del desastre climático es el capital la
lógica de relacionarnos para consumir
cada vez más para producir cada vez más
y para que algunos pocos ganen cada vez
más es eso lo que produce el desastre
climático le articularon a la lógica de
la a la acumulación ampliada del capital
los motores energéticos del Carbón y del
petróleo y desataron el huracán el
cambio químico de la atmósfera cada vez
más profundo y mortífero ahora en un
Mundo paralelo la acumulación ampliada
del capital es una acumulación ampliada
de la muerte
desde las tierras de la selva y la
belleza allí donde decidieron hacer de
una planta selvática amazónica un
enemigo
extraditar y encarcelar a sus
cultivadores les invito a detener la
guerra y a detener el desastre climático
aquí en esta selva amazónica hay un
fracaso de la humanidad
tras las hogueras que la queman tras su
envenenamiento hay un fracaso integral
civilizatorio de la humanidad
detrás de la adicción a la cocaína y a
las drogas detrás de la adicción al
petróleo y al carbón está la verdadera
adicción de esta fase de la historia
humana la adicción al poder irracional a
la ganancia
al dinero
he aquí la enorme maquinaria mortal que
puede extinguir la humanidad
Les propongo como presidente de uno de
los países más hermosos de las tierras y
de los y de los más ensangrentados y
violentados acabar la guerra contra las
drogas y todas las guerras y permitir
que nuestro pueblo pueda vivir en paz
convoco a toda América Latina en este
propósito convoco la voz de
latinoamérica unirse para derrotarlo
irracional que martiriza nuestro cuerpo
los convoco a salvar la selva amazónica
integralmente con los recursos que
puedan destinarse mundialmente a la vida
si no tienen la capacidad para financiar
el fondo de la revitalización de la
selvas si pesa más destinar el dinero
que a la vida entonces reduzca la deuda
externa para liberar nuestros propios
espacios presupuestales y con ellos
realizar la tarea de salvar la humanidad
y la vida en el planeta lo podemos hacer
nosotros y ustedes los del Norte no
quieren solo cambien deuda por vida solo
cambian deuda por naturaleza
Les propongo y los convoco en América
Latina para ello
dialogar para acabar la guerra no nos
presionen para linderarnos en los campos
de la guerra es la hora de la paz que
los pueblos eslavos hablen entre sí que
lo hagan los pueblos del mundo la guerra
es solo una trampa que acerca el fin de
los tiempos en la gran de la
irracionalidad
desde América Latina convocamos a
Ucrania y Rusia ser la paz
solo en paz podremos salvar la vida en
esta nuestra tierra común
no hay paz total sin justicia social
económica y ambiental
Estamos en guerra también con el planeta
sin paz con el planeta no habla Paz
entre las naciones
sin justicia no hay paz social Gracias
muy amable por escuchar